jean nouvel bonsoir honteux pas surpris
d'être là parce que tu es en train de
devenir le l'architecte français mais
par contre tu restes night clubbers
invétérés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on dit toujours ça mais ce qui fonde et
comprendre ces quads quand même histoire
on t'a vu industries soumises à ces
tests pour des cons pense que c'est un
sas de décompression
parce qu'en fait quand on travaille
jusqu'à 11 heures du soir jusqu'à minuit
jusqu'à 2 heures du matin qu'est-ce qui
est le plus triste que de rentrer se
coucher immédiate membres commencé dans
la matière et je repars commencé le
lendemain aussi donc je passe un quart
d'heure une demi-heure une heure
ouais quelquefois plus et puis
coucher tu es connu pour la clinique de
besoin c'est là où phare en tous les cas
au moins jeter c'était connu stepway
safin était besoin la parturiente
effectivement été derrière une fenêtre
très allongé comme comme dans un train
transportant un pensum express avec les
tours de la défense aux lointains alors
après il ya eu des mesures à nîmes
alors ça c'est fait laurent sociale
beaucoup plus tard puisque c'est ben
ouais après
l'institut du monde arabe j'ai bien aimé
le fait d'inaugurer presque en même
temps un immeuble hlm quand c'est de
nemausus est un monument sens
parisien du terme 1-1 face à l'interdît
l'hymne avec les fameux moucharabieh
c'est à dire de dire ça c'est l'image
extérieure
c'est vrai que ça sa femme parce que
j'ai quand même 25 mille îles ont
commandé par ordinateur alors cessé
d'imaginer sa frappe a fait c'est la
technologie là qui étaient utilisés à
des fins plus politique que technique ou
cuisses pour la beauté que pour
l'efficacité plus pour le symbole que
pour la performance et en fait on ose la
lumière du bâtiment uniquement pour le
plaisir
maintenant on parle beaucoup de poids en
ce moment pour sept tours de la défense
qui fait 450 de haut pas tout à fait à
bord 400 et qu'elle est qui et qui est
un rappeur de hauteur largeur de 1 à 10
alors que l'habitude c'était beaucoup
plus qui fait que ce serait une tour
très très fine c'est ça c'est une record
du monde 2 les lancements calmer les
langes heymans et le rapport de la base
à la
alors vraiment autour américaine qui
s'arrêtent à mi ciel comme ça qui sont
carrées la tienne elle ses fils et ses
fils vers le haut la caractéristique de
cette tour c'est que inapte à
l'extrémité n'a pas de fin et
symboliquement c'est un trait d'union
entre le centre de la terre et le cosmos
puisque elle disparaît dans un cratère
belle idée et on y tient absolument pas
il faudra cinq radars qui épargnent
passerelle oui et puis on voit la tour
qui disparaît de bressols comme ça et là
et en granit noir on voit pas très bien
où elle commence et puis quand on lève
la tête qu'à voir plus haut
elle se termine comme sauveur d'accéder
à plus de plancher dedans débat et
thériault et séduisant par quoi pavoiser
on voit puissent-ils à travers et toute
l'histoire esthétique c'est une sorte de
glissement progressif du plaisir et de
la matière donc c'est ce granit noir qui
fit à petit devient utile et il est
martelé il est grossier l'avoir beazley
c'est de la folie puis à lui a précédé
vert donc c'est toute la progression
comme ça qui fait que c'est un des
gradés qui du coup dans heroes tu nous
mets un restaurant bien sûr un
restaurant bien sur un belvédère
bientôt on pourra faire le tour de
france jean nouvel on ira perpignan on
ira un embout miramichi voir ce que tu
devrais avec l'hôtel que j'ai fait avec
philippe starck
tu serais qui s'il n'était pas jean
nouvel allez donc savoir
par exemple tu rejoues être peint enfin
ouais comme point de départ qui
j'aimerais être j'aurais m peut-être un
artiste dans le genre
de walter d'être des mariages comme ça
j'aurais pu être sac ou un cinéaste
j'aime beaucoup le cinéma est un jour
peut-être que je serai sur la fille est
très influencé par le cinéma parce que
tu es influencé par marvin vendeurs et
j'ai fait sa connaissance ya peu de
temps c'est avec un grand plaisir pour
moi et là ça se mérite et de plaisir
cette tour ce qui m'a envoyé une photo
qui est efficace et pour l'alliance et
par bilal est influencé par kubrick dans
la bd par le cinéma donc tout ça
finalement
l'architecturé c'est avant tout la
production de l'image donc on est
influencé par toute la production des
images de notre époque tu as dit
d'ailleurs l'avenir larchitecture n'est
pas reçue pectoral
non je crois qu'il est oui parce que ça
veut dire que l' architecture ne peut
pas se nourrir que d'elle-même elle est
obligée d'aller se ressourcer ailleurs
et discipline les arts plastiques dans
dans la publicité dans le cinéma partout
tout ce qui est une image influence leur
fait que même les avions de guerre
américains
s'il devait rester une définition de
toiles en dictionnaire ça c'est quoi
c'est pas moins de la peur du matériel
architecture ça doit être joyeux par
exemple c'est pas mal comme définition
oui
non mais je pense que celle qui donnait
existait c'est celle d'un architecte qui
s'est attaché à travailler sur les
problèmes de spécificités et d'identité
c'est à dire beaucoup de gens disent que
je suis éclectique parce qu'aucun de mes
projets
le soin sanglant fait c'est la même
méthode mais je pense pas qu'on puisse
avoir lieu pour lesquels travaillent là
j'essaie de fait être un artiste d'un
architecte qui répète toujours la main
chaude et qui veulent imposer une sorte
d'image comme femme si on avait besoin
de ça pour le connaître
j'espère que le stimulus qu'il reste à
travers ou après tout c'est différent et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible ou